well she's old enough to not have to
tell her mom well she's 28 right yeah so
I'm assuming they don't live together
well she's filming some of the content
in her mom's bedroom maybe so they do
live together hey that's rough that is
weird
[Music]
there's an only fan star who has been
shocked to discover that her mom's new
boyfriend is one of her biggest
subscribers biggest biggest oh that's
cool that's pretty cool that's cool is
that what you just said I mean I just
left the way coincidences work out
wait you're telling me you think there's
a coincidence
it just if he's just spending the money
but not watching the content Oh Long
Shot dude
come on bro yeah right dude
that just somebody bye yeah we're not
[__] shorter it's not weird he was a
subscriber
and then started dating the mom and it
was a coincidence versus dating the mom
like oh who's a [__] daughter
oh that's true yeah which
is first or but then there's also like
subscribe to the content coincidentally
dated the mom
stay subscribed or you just can't bring
it up that also is weird but you know
what is weirder you just had biggest
subscriber one of her biggest you know
what makes someone a biggest subscriber
wow what that means they're buying all
the extra [__] and they're getting like
three sites like the private videos and
[__] and that adds up to a lot of money
but what came first did he stalk her and
then start dating her mom that's the
hard part because because then if you if
you're like if you're like a huge
subscriber and you're maybe like
obsessed with them yeah and then you
like find oh this is the person's mom
and then you get cozy in because you're
trying to like get closer in some weird
strange way yeah how does it feel like
when you're the mom and your daughter's
hotter than you and then the guy that
you're with is trying to [__] your
daughter
when you put it that way I bet it's not
very good so this chick is her name is
Sophia she's 20 years old uh she talks
about how meeting her potential new
stepdad was was a very complicated
situation she talks about how on her
only fans she only does topless shots
okay
something crazy but again like Ryan
pointed out and understood this guy is
one of the bigger subscribers so even
though on the regular she's not like
huge huge but she makes like she makes
sixty uh six thousand dollars a month
roughly through subscription-based uh
only fan stuff however uh she definitely
does Private direct message type of work
as well through the platform uh she
knows specifically for this particular
dude he has not just seen topless shots
he has seen a lot more than that like a
[__]
quote we sent photos back and forth oh
see she's in his dick we've sent photos
back and forth he has seen videos of me
touching myself
so they build those shows so they've
seen each other yeah that's extra weird
yeah because not only does he pay for
the monthly subscription he's also sent
her additional uh 500 plus for uh
explicit material what's the 90s
equivalent that you subscribe to Playboy
but you also send them magazines of your
day
with articles and editorials
with a table of contents what's the 90s
equivalent of that now at this point
Sophia's mom is aware that she posts
content on only fans however the mother
doesn't know that she's taking extra
money for extra racy photos or videos or
stuff like that oh so she doesn't know
she does like the extra side contest she
doesn't know how only fans work today or
maybe as a mom you don't want to know
too much yeah well like maybe as a mom
like you're told oh it's like Playboy
and she goes oh yeah I get that dude she
should tell her mom though she's like yo
the guy that you're about to get with
all right you got to be cool with it
yeah did she not even know they were
together so the mom introduced her new
boyfriend to uh what's her name Sophia
and you're like you're shy guy okay she
was like this is a basically this is a
man I fell head over heels for uh at the
gym
so they met at the gym and she like is
Head Over Heels after weeks of stalking
at the gym yeah but was was she like oh
hi and then he's like
she said he he looked sheepish when we
met and that's what creeped me out the
most sheepish has his like oh my God
like guilty uh like he went for what the
[__]
quivering uh this is bad damn dude and
the funny thing is uh Sophia also
mentioned that she actually shoots some
of her content in her mom's bedroom
yo damn this is a so this guy might end
up buying his own content on her page
what if subconsciously he basically
wants her right and she sees someone
like her that's more appropriate to his
age which is her mom and he's like oh my
God my my kind of my dream you'll do and
then they get together
he manifested it right because she's
basically like I don't know like the 40
80 year old I'll get the iOS 2 version
I'll get last year's model last year
this model she's like yeah she's like
the iPods you know
the iPod Touch yes what other analogies
you got yeah what else I'll get the legs
or this version of this movie
yeah so of course she's concerned that
you know maybe this subscriber uh
stalked her got obsessed found out who
her mom was I think that's a fair
concern
I just think he saw her at the gym and
go you're almost like my dream girl like
the one I jack off to but I think you're
almost there so let's go I think that's
kind of a crazy uh like attempt to even
get at the mom yeah through her only
fans yeah right it's almost like how you
back up the Mom it's almost so crazy
that it was like premeditated you think
so you don't think it's like
coincidental oh it's not Serendipity it
could be I think we have to say that
it's a possibility but like chances are
if you're a top earner if you're
spending all that money I bet you would
go to the extra lengths of being like
let me see what I can do do we have a
video or picture what she looks like
can you buy one real quick
can you pay for one real fast yeah that
happened to me one time well some some
not even similar but embarrassing out of
one of the parties a long time ago I was
just chatting up with this girl and then
um she she was like oh do you have
Instagram you know that whole [__] and I
was like yeah put your thing in she put
her Instagram in I was already following
her oh [__] and I was like oh [__]
it's like [__] that's embarrassing
Instagram does bury [__] let's kind of
tight too well I just didn't think I
just didn't realize it was her oh okay
well like I really was following what
are you like you're a catfish dude you
look nothing like this she did I just
hadn't thought of it I just looked like
a weirdo it's like oh God damn it
there's no photo of her
um but in terms of the situation is
everybody on the same page here like
what would you do what would you tell
her to do in her situation
what would I do if I was the guy no no
like what would you tell her to do let's
say that she said if he's a big customer
I don't want to ruin that's your mom no
bro just don't hang out with their mama
that's a tough one though yeah it's true
you can't tell your mom you wouldn't
tell your mom because if she's
money-minded that is a hard call yeah
how much is it or just [__] him oh oh
actually no no you don't want to it's a
customer she doesn't want it never mind
that's a movie on the Hub that's my
fantasy sorry if she makes six G's a
month
is five of it from him because if it is
just leave everything alone
[Laughter]
you walk away
take your money but if it's like one
tell your mom dude
that's tough because this guy could be a
total creep you don't know because then
if it's based on like whose set of
morals is the decision based on you
gotta tell the mom to start charging him
like yo mom look how much money I'm
making off of it you don't gotta do this
for free you don't gotta live like this
Mom it's kind of true that's rough but I
definitely think her safety is a little
bit at risk I think that's weird for
sure because he's gonna be in the other
room like oh I want that [__] so bad
well because who wants to know who wants
the confirmed thought that your
stepdad's jacking it to you yep that's
weird and you know that yeah he's a
customer right and you've interacted and
you know what his dick looks like don't
worry Sophie I'll do the laundry this
week you're like
and the fact that he's active on your
only fan so that means while you're in
the same house you guys might just be
chatting anyway oh [__] dude that's
weird yeah there's all sorts of wrong
and the funny thing is like I think I
think it would be easy enough for most
people to conclude like yo like there's
a problem there you need to if you're
not gonna tell your mom that you need a
for sure end something about this you
know what I mean what if he stopped
her only fan subscriptions after that
after he if he saw that and was like
what the [__] and then he stopped
everything then imagine this fast
forward years down the line it's like
it's your new stepdad but he happened to
maybe what save [__] videos of you
touching yourself that he paid four
years prior you never told anybody yeah
you know what I'm saying like there's
only one such a slippery slope I think
there is only one way out the one way
out is he messages her and says sorry I
gotta stop spending because I actually
love your mom and this is done like this
was a fun fantasy but I actually like
your mom right then that at least shows
a step forward of like that's an awesome
guy of like yeah a concept of nobility
yeah I'm horny dude do you think but
then like that's if he actually wanted
to be with her mom and not with her oh I
see you know like so then it's like it
could be a mistake that's the mistake
angle yeah yeah the other one
coincidence yeah is he would have to
come clean if he came clean then he can
save of that relationship but it still
makes it so [__] awkward or he goes
hey yo my bad I [__] up blah blah and
then he gets a new burner account and
then buys some more and then he's like
yo do you think if he put it all out on
the table that the relationship would
survive that kind of confession I don't
know bro not not in the early stages
right that's a big one that is a pretty
big one but just as well not in the late
stages right like that's a that's a
crazy one in any stage that's a big one
and then also what what like are you
putting the mother and daughter's
relationship in jeopardy too because if
like oh like should you just keep your
mouth shut and just peace out what kind
of because let's say he's the one who's
like hey I made a mistaken because it's
like why didn't the daughter you know
what I mean talk to her as well it's
like what are you gonna you know what
I'm saying and it's like plus it's like
the mom doesn't even know that this
daughter's doing the extra [__] outside
only fans well she's old enough to not
have to tell her mom well she's 28 right
yeah so I'm assuming they don't live
together well she's filming some of the
content in her mom's bedroom maybe so
they do live together
let me tell you something Japanese about
California
[Music]